werte fest und ehrengäste werte
angehörige zuallererst erlauben sie mir
die herzlichen größe von unserem
bundesminister kunasek an den leuten
anteil weiter zu geben hat ein
besonderer tag für sie ein tag an dem
sie nicht nur die akademische weihen
bekommen haben sondern auch zum leutnant
befördert wurden diesbezüglich ein
besonderes dankeschön als
generalsekretär habe sie dass sie sich
diesen herausforderungen im rahmen einer
sehr fordernden ausbildung gestellt
haben und diese auch positiv absolviert
haben
der jahrgang reichsgraf von abensberg
und rauen ein besonderer jahrgang mit
denen ich persönlich sicherlich auf
ewigkeit verbunden bleibe nicht nur
deswegen weil ich das vergnügen hatte
bei meinem ersten auftritt als
generalsekretär die theresianischen
militärakademie besuchen durfte beim
neujahrsempfang folglich auch beim
offiziers ball gast sein durfte und im
rahmen dieser festlichkeiten die jungen
herren schon kennenlernen durfte und
mich schon damals vom dame vom zahllosen
auftreten um vom glitzern in den augen
dieser herrn persönlich einen eindruck
machen konnte ja wenn man den jahrgangs
kann man da ein prosit neujahr dr
weiter wem der abschied schmerzt so muss
auch ich für mich selbst sagen jedes mal
wenn ich zurückkehre an die theresia
einmal mutter dann geht es mir endlich
wenn man hier vier jahre verbracht hat
in der offiziersausbildung dann
verbindet das jeden österreichischen
offizier lebenslang so denke ich mit
diesem ort
mit dieser kameradschaft mit diesen
prüfungen herausforderungen aber auch
gemeinschaft und immer der stolze
vorwärts blicken was immer auch auf uns
zukommen mag
wir verstehen als hier an dieser
akademie einen offizier zu bilden den
wir für die herausforderungen brauchen
denen sie ab montag gegenüber stehen
werden herausforderungen die es um eine
ich mit dem zivilen leben außer auch in
einsatzorganisationen nur schwer
vergleichbar ist
zwei erlebnisse als general fecker der
die mir zeit denn was auf sie auf jeden
einzelnen von ihnen zu kommen kann
das soll jetzt nicht im festlichen
rahmen trüben aber es soll uns doch den
ernst der aufgaben der zukunft vor augen
führen gemeinsam
wir erinnern uns an den koran vorfall
wie medial österreichischer soldaten als
mörder bezeichnet wurden von einem tag
auf den anderen schon zig jahre
zurückliegend für uns eine enorme
herausforderung wir wussten gar nicht
wer damals wirklich auf dieser position
dienst versah wir wussten zwar werde die
kommandanten waren wir konnten die
personen nicht gleich anrufen uns kein
klares lagebild verschaffen
wir haben aber dank bundesminister
kunasek keine vorverurteilung getroffen
wir haben im rahmen achsen kommission in
ruhe den sachverhalt aufbereitet und
schließlich mit unserer bewertung der
staatsanwaltschaft übergeben
was will ich damit sagen sie kommen in
ein alter wo sie
mit der bereitschaft mit der waffe in
der hand für sie für die österreichische
bevölkerung einzustehen sie als
offiziere müssen entscheidungen treffen
in unklare situationen hinein oft wo sie
selbst nicht wissen ist es mit ja oder
mit nein für sich selbst zu beantworten
dahingehend ist es auch notwendig gefühl
zu besitzen herz hirn humor
verantwortung gegenüber ihren
untergebenen und dass sie mit ihnen
gemeinsam eine kampfgemeinschaft bilden
und nicht nur vorgesetzter sind eine
zweite herausforderung die jetzt gerade
medial genüsslich ausgebreitet
ausgebreitet wird das ist das busunglück
in hainburg für die herrn pioniere unter
uns auch ein wunderschöner samstag
was ausbildung mit jungen damen die
prämien für das österreichische
bundesheer sich dafür interessieren
freiwillig sondern wochenende eindrücken
mit pionier boten denen die wir ihnen
übergeben haben mit dem versprechen mehr
oder weniger unsinkbar zu sein und
plötzlich von einer sekunde zur anderen
können sie ab montag in einer situation
gestellt werden die sich zu einem wahren
albtraum entwickeln kann
nichtsdestotrotz sie haben hier die
ausbildung ruhe zu bewahren
ursache feststellen fehler beheben
auf keinen fall den nerven verlieren
ruhig gefasst im sinne ihrer
untergebenen und zum schutz der
österreichischen bevölkerung verhandeln
ich kann ihnen eines garantieren die
generalität die höheren offiziere
stabsoffiziere ober offiziere aber auch
ihre unteroffiziere werden wenn sie
diese werte mit leben gefüllt zu ihm
stehen in guten und in schlechten zeiten
das möchte ich ihnen heute auf ihrem
lebensweg mitgeben
ab montag stehen sie in verantwortung
alles gute diesbezüglich lang lebe der
jahrgang reichsgraf von abensberg und
raum
lang lebe in der neustadt lang lebe das
bundesland niederösterreich
lang lebe die theresianischen
militärakademie aus unserer heimat als
offiziere
lang lebe das österreichische bundesheer
lang lebe die zweite republik vielen
dank
[Applaus]